>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH, THE PUSH
TO CUT RED TAPE FOR FINDING A
VACCINE, WHERE THE PLASMA,
THAT’S WHERE WERE GOING TO START
WITH OUR NEW GUEST.
WELCOME BACK TO FOX NEWS AT
NIGHT, GOOD TO HAVE YOU.
>> THINKING
>> LET’S TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
VACCINE, THIS IS WHAT HE SAID
TODAY, WHEN HE WAS AT THE TIME
FRAME, HE WAS TALKING ABOUT
12-18 MONTHS.
HERE’S WHAT HE SAID.
>> THE VACCINE, AS HE SAID, IT’S
ON TARGET.
WERE STILL IN PHASE ONE, TWO
MONTHS FROM NOW WE WILL BE IN
PHASE TWO.
IT WILL BE A YEAR, TO A YEAR AND
A HALF.
>> THERE ARE SOME SKEPTICS OUT
THERE, TALKING ABOUT THE TIME
FRAMES AS THE REALITY IS, THAT’S
PROBABLY NOT GOING TO HAPPEN.
WE MAY HAVE REAL OPTIMISM AND
SOME SAFETY EVIDENCE, BUT NOT A
VACCINE.
WHAT SAY YOU?
IT SEEMS LIKE DR. FAUCI SEEMS
PRETTY GUARDED ABOUT THINGS THAT
HE’S PUT OUT THERE, HE SEEMS
RATHER CONFIDENT ABOUT THIS.
>> LET’S STICK WITH DR. FAUCI,
I’VE KNOWN HIM FOR MANY YEARS,
HE IS A WORLD EXPERT IN THIS,
FOR A VACCINE TO WORK, IT NEEDS
TO BE SAFE.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT GIVING IT
TO 300 MILLION AMERICANS, IT HAS
TO BE EFFECTIVE.
YOU’RE GOING TO GIVE IT TO A LOT
OF PEOPLE, IT HAS TO MAKE SURE
NO ONE OF THOSE FOLKS IS HARMED
BY IT.
IF THERE EXPLODES TO THE VIRUS,
IT NEEDS TO WORK FOR THEM
TO BE ABLE TO FEND IT OFF.
I’M VERY EXCITED ABOUT THE
RESEARCH THAT IS BEING DONE.
RESEARCHERS ARE REALLY MAKING
THE DIFFERENCE, THIS IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT IS GOING TO BE
DEVELOPED OVERNIGHT.
BUT IF WE CAN HAVE THIS DONE IN
THE KIND OF TIME THAT DR. FAUCI
TALKS ABOUT, THAT WOULD BE A
WORLD RECORD.
>> Shannon: IT WOULD.
I WANT TO PLAY SOMETHING ELSE,
FROM TODAY.
SHE TALKS ABOUT THE ANTIBODY
TEST THAT IF WE CAN RAMP UP THE
TASK THAT WOULD ALLOW PEOPLE TO
SEE IF THEY HAD COVID-19
RECOVERED FROM IT, THEY WOULD BE
ABLE TO THEN MOVE ABOUT SAFELY.
SHE WAS SAYING PRIMARILY FOR
HEALTH CARE WORKERS.
SHE’S PUT OUT A CHALLENGE.
>> I THINK REALLY BEING ABLE TO
TELL THEM, THE PEACE OF MIND
THAT WOULD COME FROM KNOWING YOU
ALREADY WERE INFECTED, YOU
ANTIBODIES.
IF YOU’RE SAFE FROM REINFECTION,
99 POINTS BLUNT OF THE TIME
IT WOULD BE REASSURING TO THE
FRONT LINE.
OUR UNIVERSITIES CAN DO THAT BY
FRIDAY.
>> Shannon: A BYE FRIDAY, THAT
SOUNDS AMAZING.
SHE USED A LITTLE TERMINOLOGY I
DIDN’T UNDERSTAND, BUT SHE TALKS
ABOUT HOW IT IS HAPPENED BEFORE.
TO HAVE SOMETHING AVAILABLE TO
SOON, WHAT KIND OF ROLE CUT OUR
UNIVERSITIES PLAY IN GETTING
SOMETHING LIKE THIS OUT THERE
AND KNOW IF THEY ARE SAFE.
>> THIS WOULD BE THE REAL
GAME CHANGER, NOT JUST FOR OUR
HEALTH CARE WORKERS, BUT FOR ALL
OF OUR WORKERS IN AMERICA.
WE TALK ABOUT PEOPLE THAT MAY
HAVE HAD THE VIRUS, BUT ARE
SILENT CARRIERS.
THEY HAVE DEVELOPED IN THERE
BODY, THEIR ABILITY TO FIGHT
THIS OFF.
BY DOING THE SIMPLE BLOOD TEST,
IF WE COULD FIND THAT THEY
HAD -- WHO THESE PEOPLE ARE WHO
HAVE BUILT UP THESE ANTIBODIES,
THEY COULD GO OUT AND WORK IN
THE COMMUNITIES, THE HOSPITALS,
GET BACK TO LIFE AS NORMAL.
WE WOULD HAVE A MUCH BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF HOW VULNERABLE
WE WEAR A SOCIETY, AND WHO IS
SAFE TO MAKE A BIG DIFFERENCE IN
OUR RECOVERY.
>> Shannon: HOW QUICKLY COULD
SOMETHING LIKE THAT BE SCALED?
SHE TALKED ABOUT FRIDAY.
THESE ARE RELATIVELY CHEAP ONCE
THEY GET IT GOING.
THAT SOMETHING THAT YOU THINK
COULD BE BROADLY AVAILABLE TO
RETURN TO WORK IN HEALTH CARE,
WHETHER IT’S RESTAURANTS, BANKS,
SMALL BUSINESSES, WHATEVER ELSE
MAY BE OUT THERE.
>> I THINK IT WOULD REALLY HELP
IN OPENING UP THE ECONOMY
DRAMATICALLY FOR A COUNTRY, IF
WE KNEW THERE WERE ENOUGH PEOPLE
THAT MET THIS CRITERIA.
SO THE QUESTION IS, WHERE CAN
YOU GET THE TASK?
HOW MANY OF THE TESTS ARE
AVAILABLE?
THIS WOULD BE DONE AT A REGULAR
POINT OF CONTACT OR DO YOU HAVE
TO SEND IT IN AND WAIT SEVERAL
DAYS LIKE YOU DO NOW?
THIS WOULD MAKE A REAL
DIFFERENCE THIS WOULD BE A BLOOD
TEST.
A SEROLOGY TEST, TO SEE IF YOUR
BODY HAS BUILT UP ANTIBODIES TO
FIGHT CORONAVIRUS, IT’S ONE OF
THE TEST THEY WERE DOING IN
SOUTH KOREA PREVIOUSLY.
IT WOULD MAKE A BIG DIFFERENCE
IN TERMS OF WHEN AMERICA OPENS
UP AND GETS BACK TO BUSINESS.
>> Shannon: LET ME ASK YOU
ALSO ABOUT THE PLASMA USE.
I’VE SEEN A NUMBER OF
UNIVERSITIES AND HEALTH CARE
GROUPS AND HOSPITAL GROUPS BRING
OUT THE CALL.
IF YOU’RE SOMEONE WHO HAD
CORONAVIRUS, IF YOU HAVE
RECOVERED, COULD YOU COME IN AND
GIVE PLASMA?
THEY SAY THEY DON’T KNOW IT’S A
GUARANTEE.
THEY SAY IT WORKED IN THE PAST.
>> I THINK THERE IS A LOT OF
OPTIMISM FOR THAT.
WE SAW THAT WORK IN THE CASE OF
EBOLA AND AFRICA.
PEOPLE THAT HAD THAT, AND HAD
GOTTEN OVER, THOSE ARE THE
PEOPLE THAT THEN WERE HOPING TO
TREAT PEOPLE AS WELL IS BEING
USED AS PART OF THE TREATMENT OF
THE PEOPLE WITH EBOLA.
IT MADE A BIG DIFFERENCE, IT
WORKS ALSO FOR CORONAVIRUS, THAT
WOULD BE SIGNIFICANT FOR ALL OF
US.
>> Shannon: SENATOR AND